hello everyone and welcome to another
game you guys requested from the
meltwater Champions Chester finals it is
the second game of the match Magnus
Carlson versus pragnananda the first
game was won by Magnus if you've seen
the previous video uh you know uh how
how that happened uh Prague tried to
sacrifice for the attack but Magnus
found one way that he could not only
survive the attack but also win the game
after he defended well uh and now this
is the second game again it's a fairly
similar Magnus will try to simplify
things Prague will try to keep it
complicated he will try to attack but
what's really awesome about this game is
that it follows exactly uh not move by
move because it actually transposes into
that position later on in the game uh
game eight of the world to championship
match between Magnus Carlsen and Sergey
kariakin uh that kayaking won very
nicely as a Magnus blundered terribly in
the end game uh so we'll see what a
Magnus prepared if he even prepared
something because of course that's one
of the games that I believe Magnus
analyze is the more than any in his life
it is the uh the one game that he
actually lost in a world cheers
championship match uh so let's see how
how uh how how they uh played out uh
Pawn to B3 this is what Magnus goes for
here this is the names of Larson attack
and uh like I said we will transpose
into that game Pawn to D5 a very
principal reply he probably grabs the
center we have Bishop to B2 controlling
the uh Central with the pieces and now
Knight to F6 we have Knight to F3 and C5
so this is a very nicely done by Prague
E3 and now Pawn to E6 we have Pawn to D4
and Bishop to D6 uh D characters and C5
making the bishop waste the tempo Bishop
captures and C5 and now Pawn to C4
challenging black center here castles
and now Knight beat the D2 We have Queen
to E7 and now A3 with Ponte A5 and the
bishop to D3 D captures on C4 Knight cap
prison C4 and now Bishop B6 preparing to
develop the light Square Bishop castles
and now Knight beta D7 we have Knight to
D4 by Magnus and here uh Prague plays
Bishop to B7 and this is the position
from game 8 of the wheelchair
championship match between Magnus
Carlsen
Magnus also had the white pieces there
and in that game Magnus played Queen to
E2 it's not the move that lost him the
game but uh probably he's not very fond
of it so here he goes Bishop to E2 which
is the uh first uh and or absolute
strongest move recommended by the engine
so we know that Magnus has looked into
that that game but probably Prague has
as well Knight the E4 now bringing the
Knight um to this wonderful E4 Square
also freeing up the F6 Square for the
other Knight which will just
improve the uh well just a Black's
pieces Bishop to F3 now Magnus wants the
counter uh progress a very strong light
Square bishop and B7 and Knight D2 F6
with Queen to C2 putting pressure on e4
but uh proc has a very very nice control
over D4 Square Rook 8 to C8 aligning The
Rook nicely with the queen here and pawn
to A4 stopping any future B5 ideas and
here we have Bishop to D5 not sure if
this formation has an name or anything
but it definitely should have a name we
have Rook 8 to C1 H6 and now Queen to E2
getting the queen out of that Rooks um C
file Rook F to d8 and now Rook F to D1
and look at this it's like they are they
are composing This Together such a such
a nice position to see uh Knight stage
seven pragma wants to improve the
position of this Knight as well he wants
to come to G5 put pressure on the F3
Bishop Bishop capture Sunny for Magnus
gives up the bishop pair Bishop captures
and now Knight to B5 offering a trade of
Rooks along the D file uh Queen to G5
process thank you very much I'm gonna go
for checkmate here F3 blocking Checkmate
and the now uh Rook captures on D1 you
can't capture an E3 the Knight to
defends the E3 square but the proc has a
way of trying to get to that square so
Rook captures on D1 Rook captures and
now Bishop to D5 threatening to remove
the defender of the E3 pawn and then
just pick up the pawn so Bishop to D4
Magnus has to block this bishop capture
Sandy for E Capture Sun D4 and now uh
Prague has to make a very uh important
decision the B6 Pawn is hanging thus he
wants does he want to defend it with
some like Queen to d8 it does bring the
queen back to the starting square and uh
really really wants to move forward and
I'll go backwards so he goes Knight to
F6 he sacrifices the pawn and now he
wants to bring the Knight to H5 to F4
and then uh just Checkmate Magnus and
the Magnus says all right uh let's see
what you got so Knight captures on B6 we
have rooked the C1 now offering a trade
of Rooks and Magnus just goes back
Knight to C4 now no longer is Bishop
captures on B3 and option and he is
attacking the A5 Pawn as well now it's
interesting in the previous game as well
Prague sacrifice for the attack and we
said that if Magnus is able to defend
off the attack he will just be winning
because of the past pawns and here also
he has a two to one advantage on the
queen side if he can start pushing those
pawns should be very good for him Knight
to H5 Rook captures on C1 Queen captures
on C1 with check King to F2 and now just
Bishop captures and C4 we have Queen
captures and C for offering a queen
trade but now Queen to B2 check probably
not interested in a queen trade King the
E3 and now Queen captures and G2 so
Prague was down upon but now he wins
back his pawn and uh well he's just
better here magnus's King is in a really
really bad position and the Queen and
Knight like we said make a great
attacking combo uh D5 by Magnus uh we
have Queen to G1 with check King to D3
and now Queen to D1 with check best was
the capture on H2 because it um doesn't
really give white all that many options
if you capture here first Knight to F4
check the queen now covers the F4 square
and once the king moves you're gonna
pick up the east 6 pawn and now uh okay
white white does have some play but
black should be better hard to save
black can win this but black will be
much better but in the game Queen to D1
check was played King to E3 and now
Queen to E1 checking to D3 now Queen to
B1 check and now Magnus plays King to D2
and he says now you are no longer able
to win this uh because uh well there's
just no good way to play this if you
play a queen to B2 check I'm just gonna
move the king uh and this is well if
Prague wants he can just force a draw
key a queen B1 Queen B2 Queen B1 Queen
B2 or even he can go for something like
this and then maybe even capture the H2
Pawn but then the D6 Pawn starts
marching forward which is also very
dangerous still it will be enough for
him to get a draw but in the game after
King the D2 e captures on D5 was played
and now uh there is a problem in the
position uh the position is now
completely winning for Magnus there's a
problem in the position for prank uh so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for Magnus while I give you
a couple of seconds
foreign
this dirty trick and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Queen the C8 check the only move that
wins forces King to H7 this is the only
move for black king to H7 and now you
force a queen trade Queen to C2 with
check Queen captures and King captures
so that was the secret weapon and it's
very easy to solve positions like these
and play chess as well as Magnus does if
you can just imagine queens of the board
and you figure out okay this is a
completely winning position for me and
I'm sure you guys know why it's a
completely winning position for white
but uh okay I could like I could give
you a pause the video moment because
because I really know all of you know
how to solve this Brock played King to
G6 and now uh for the second time feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for Magnus while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations on uh well
always uh trying that first it's the
strongest movie in every game and so it
is the strongest move in this game and
of course that is Pawn to B4 so
congratulations to everyone who found
this uh as I'm pretty sure no one just
enjoyed the show on this one upon the B4
wins the game uh there's nothing you can
do about it it will create a past Pawn
or if a capture some B4 what proc played
then Pawn to A5 and now luckily uh
prog's knight from H5 can still catch up
to the pawn Knight to F6 A6 Knight to D7
A7 and Knight to B6 so the A8 square the
queening square is guarded but now
Magnus brings the king into the game
King B6 King F6 sorry King B3 King F6
King captures on B4 Knight the A8 now
King to C5 King to E7 and now King the
C6 we have King to d8 and now uh King
the B7 and here prog just plays King to
F6 he offers Magnus a full night and if
Magnus captures Prague will just trap
his King like this and okay the position
is still winning for for Magnus but
Magnus doesn't want to mess around like
this he just goes backing the C6 he he
doesn't want the the free Knight H5 uh
and now King captures on D5 King to D7
we have King to C5 and now Pawn to G5
proc starts advancing his pawns King to
D5 Now Pawn to G4 captures captures and
now King the E4 wheel King to C6 now
Knights the C3 we have King to B7 and
now King to F5 and uh interestingly uh
it's now possible to save the game for
frog it's it's an extremely difficult
um uh move to find uh Prague didn't find
it in the game but luckily you guys are
are here and I will make this the third
pause the video moment because the game
is so complicated like I mentioned in
the previous video whenever Magnus and
proc play they Place games that are so
complicated you have a chance to make a
mistake on pretty much every move so
feel free to pause the video for the
third time and try and save this game
for Prague while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are who were
able to do it congratulations as you are
a true master of uh incredibly difficult
end games and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Pawn to G3
such a silly move to play yes because uh
the king will capture the the G4 pawn
and that's what proc thought that's why
he didn't go for it in the game he
played the Knight the C7 and then he
allowed King characters and G4 but with
Pawn to G3 you force H captors on G3 and
now after H captors and G3 now you play
Knight to B6 and now check this out king
captures on F6 King captures an A7 G4 it
seems like your Pawn is Unstoppable but
that could not be further from the truth
uh King to B7 look at this a king a G5
Knight to D7 check and now you don't
have a good Square for your king and
this is something that you should uh
remember as you might just resign in in
a game in a position like this but here
it's actually impossible to win because
Magnus can always uh or rather proc can
always sacrifice this Knight for a pawn
if you go King to E7 95 and the G6
square is covered if you go back and you
have 697 check if you try King F7 Knight
the E5 check if you try King to E6 then
you block the pawn Knight the G6 if you
bring the Knight into the game just
Knight H4 and you are never Crossing
that a G6 Square because the Knight will
just capture it if King F6 you're just
gonna play King to C6 if G6 you're just
gonna capture it King characters King
captures and that's it even if you save
the Knight it doesn't really matter you
can move the Knight let's say you play
the Knight gives check King to D7 you
bring the Knight somewhere you bring the
Knight over here just King the d8 and
again there's no way for you to actually
cross the G6 square and that's how you
save this it's pretty tough to spot from
from here but uh I mean it's hard in a
classical game of course everyone finds
this uh by everyone I mean uh players
who are playing this both Magnus and
Prague would find this but in a rapid
game with less than a minute on the
clock not so much night the C7 was
played and now Magnus just gobbles up
the G4 Pawn Knights the E6 with King to
F5 Knights the D4 check and King to E4
he just wants to start advancing his
past H Pawn Knight the E6 and pawn to H4
we have Knight to G7 Knight to B5 now
Advent guarding the pawn and because uh
you you could have captured the pawn but
then the pawn would just uh March
forward much faster this way Prague
created a barricade here so the white
king cannot get across but now uh of
course Magnus had time to save the pawn
with Knight to the B5 King to A8 we have
King to F4 we have King to B7 now Prague
is forced to just move the king back and
forth King G4 King to A8 and now Knight
to D6
again if you try H5 here uh it's uh not
gonna work because just Knight captures
an H5 King captures and F5 this is a a
draw a different kind of a draw but a
draw I will show it because I know you
guys might be interested King B7 and
there's no way to kick away the black
king from the corner King D5 King T8
you're just gonna uh bring your king
closer and now after King C5 and King
here uh you cannot put the king to B6
because it's stalemate and if you try to
go around let the game be seven King get
five King here you still can't put the
king here or here because it's against
stalemate you will take away the B7
Square from the black king so this will
again be a draw uh it would be ideal if
you could have your Pawn defended by the
king and then deliver a check with the
Knight but that's not happening so
luckily Magnus did not play this he goes
Knight to D6 with King captures an A7
Knight to F5 now offering a trade of
knights and that of course wouldn't be
winning for Magnus 96 and only now H5 so
you can see how much preparation took
into advanced in the pawn just to that
H5 Square King to B6 H6 we have Knight
to f8 guarding the H7 square but now
Knights the D4 very tricky stuff it
prevents King C5 because Knight E6 check
forces the knights to capture and then
H7 is Unstoppable and uh aside from that
you don't really have much Knight H7 was
played King F5 King to C5 and now King
G6 Magnus offers the Knight here for the
Knight on H7 so Knight G5 and now just
King captures an F6 Knight H7 checking
G6 Knight to f8 check King G7 and it was
in this position and move 74 that
pregnant resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh once the
Knight moves uh Knight to these seven
years gonna play uh okay you can even
save the Knight Knight F3 then H7 h8
there's no way for the Knight to
actually uh stir some trouble here so
after King to G7 he resigned and Magnus
wins his second game in a row and the
third game between the two of them ended
in a draw which means Magnus wins the
match which means that Magnus wins the
Melt weather Champions Chester finals a
full a full uh round before the
tournament finishes even though we said
that as Duda was playing incredibly well
in the tournament that he will probably
face judai in the final round and that
could decide the outcome of the
tournament uh now that match will have
no significance whatsoever on the
outcome of the tournament as Magnus wins
uh just a full round ahead these are the
standings uh if you guys are interested
before the before the final round starts
so Magnus in first place with 17 points
uh incredible stuff Wesley still in
second with 12 then do that in third
with 10. Arjun irrigation
last with four points uh tough
tournament for foreign
uh but yeah uh that's the game I hope
you guys enjoyed it very nicely played
by Magnus uh I mean this is truly an
outstanding performance but like uh it's
like you said in a tournament uh in an
interview yesterday they uh asked him
does does he feel uh that he should win
more games uh now that he basically
resigned his worldshire championship
title without without uh fighting for it
uh he said most definitely is that he
wants to win absolutely everything and
uh he he just wants to win every
tournament every game that is uh that is
what uh motivates him that is what it
drives him we'll see how long that will
be possible uh hopefully for a very long
time uh so yeah that's the game I really
hope you guys enjoyed it and that you've
learned something about the end game
like uh the the entire game was
incredibly complicated just throughout
the game and then especially the end
game I mean that if that would be tough
to play in a classical game let alone in
a rapid uh so I once again really hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to wish
a very happy birthday to Luke Bastian
and and I would like to thank Francis
air Carmen polifrronio Sinister pawn and
ravishing reptiles YouTube for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
this wonderful event uh and whatever you
uh guys I think uh I'm I should show or
maybe suggest and you know whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day